Hello, Mike.
Hey, buddy.
Hey, Mike.
I don't.
Hi, Ruby.
Hey, Tom.
Hi, Tom.
What's up? What's up?
I only missed you on the last one.
I don't want.
Oh.
I think okay. Can you hear me okay?
Cool.
Great.
So Kris will be joining in shortly. He is wrapping up a call. That's great.
From New Mexico, I think Andrew will join. That's what I'm expecting.
Like, is this the first time you are like part of this meeting?
I'm sure I've joined before, but not very often, not very often. And I only have a little bit of time this morning or this afternoon. It's noon for me. So I'll give you as much time as I can.
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah.
Mhm.
I appreciate it, Mike. Thank you. I know Larry, he joins from East Coast since you're managing West Coast. So obviously, Tom, you're speaking on mute.
Kour.
Larry's in Canada, I don't think he's gonna join today.
Oh, okay.
I could be wrong, but I don't think so. David will not join today.
How about David?
Everyone is, it seems like everyone is super busy.
I know.
Abe.
Is it because of Q2 pressure?
That's, who knows? Change of seasons, who knows what it is?
And be heading to our summers are pretty busy, right?
Kind of slows down, at least from a New York perspective. I mean, usually the summertime people are on BTO, it slows down a little bit, but...
Mhm.
Not lately, that's for sure. Hold on one second, guys, sorry.
Yeah, no worries.
I did notice Ryan declined the call as well, so Ryan won't be in.
Oh, so Ryan is not joining? Okay.
Yeah.
Uh, Curtis seems to be available, then I see.
Gagan also available, not sure if they have time to join.
Yeah, we'll wait for one more minute. We'll wait for two more minutes. Mike, if that's okay with you. I just want to make sure that everyone is in.
Sure.
Start.
And I believe Tom, you have not met, you did not meet Manish, right?
No, I think this is the first time. How you doing?
Okay, great.
Yeah, I'm doing great, Tom. Thanks for asking.
Manish is helping me. He is, as we expand, as we grow, so he is helping me with people management. So that's why you see more of him as per the people communication. But that does not mean that I'm going anywhere. I'm here, but he's just supporting me.
Yeah.
OK, so Manish, why don't you take a minute and introduce yourself, and then probably then I will start with the presentation.
Yep.
Sure.
Thanks.
Thank you, Kevin. Hi, Tom. Hi, Mike. My name is Manish. I've been working with IT by Design for, I recently completed 11 years on Monday. So, it's been 11 years, 11 lovely years with IT by Design. Learnt A lot. I started as a level one engineer, now working as in a capacity of senior technical team lead.
Hi.
And if you talk about Cohen, I've been working with Kevin for almost 8 to 9 years now.
So yep, since I joined IT by design, I've been working with him. I have seen him grow as well. Like he was in a call taking role like an engineer and then right now working in a ESTM, let's see.
a motivation for me to move further. That's what I have right now.
And yeah, that's it for me.
This is the Nikki.
K, great.
All right, welcome aboard.
Thank Yu.
Thank you, Manish. So I've already updated Manish as for all the...
Yes.
People management stuff. He's aware that you're from New York, PA specifically. He knows other parts as well.
Okay, so let me share my screen. By the way, we are recording this session, so if someone needs to re-watch, they can just go through the video. Let me know when you can see my screen. By the way, welcome, Andrea.
I know I pronounced it incorrectly. I'll call you Eddie.
Thanks, Kevin.
Yeah.
That's OK.
TA.
Hey, Kris.
Hello, how we doing?
Just in time, Kris, just in time. How you doing?
Hey, Kris.
Doing well, how are you guys doing?
Good, good. Thank you. Okay, so thank you so much for joining in. We'll be looking at March month's data. This is our monthly service check-in for ITBD Solutions. Looking at the agenda item, it stayed the same. No major change. We'll go through highlights, performance analysis.
End user sentiments, US holiday schedule, AI by design, way forward, and then meeting minutes. Quick highlights from last month, Stellen is independently handling the RMW client and has received multiple positive CSAF from users.
That's great to see. Thank you, Kris, for supporting Stellan. Next up, Sheila, selected as Sheila's placement on the New Mexico port and has started working on the tickets. The ITBD.
Teams average billable utilization in March reached 75% and ticket closure rate was at 85%. Ralph and Kyle continue to provide solid business support over the weekend.
So these are the few highlights from last month. Before we move forward, Chris, Tom, Mike, anything that you want to add?
PH.
Yep, good.
All right. Moving on as per the performance analysis, looking at New Mexico port specifically, Kristine, Nathan, Stella, Nixon, Nathan 72, Stella and Nixon 89 and 88 respectively. Then Ralph and Kyle were at 62 and 51 percent.
Rico, that's the St. Louis team. He was around 62%. The New Mexico team, Leah, Shirley, Jamie, they all exceeded their benchmark score. And the Kansas, we have Matthew at 82%. So that's the performance review for the entire group.
Team is performing well. I believe the only thing that I would need Manish support is to make sure that they are not meeting but exceeding the benchmark APIs. So that is where we will be focusing in Q2.
But any questions, anyone, before we move on to the next KP, that is the ticket closure rate.
Nope, good from my end.
Mike, please feel free to interrupt me if you have any questions. I'll be more than happy to answer.
No, it's good so far. It's. Thank you.
Your voice is breaking up, Mike. I don't know if I'm the only one.
No, I have the worst internet connection in the world right now. I apologize.
Ohh.
No worries, no worries. It's okay. Thank you. Moving on as per the ticket closure rate, everyone, entire team was able to exceed their ticket closure rate. Kyle was 6% below, but I think as per the entire group.
They all exceeded New York, specifically Nathan 96, Stellan 85, Nixon 81, Ralph 84%. Rico was 80% with his closure rate. New Mexico team, Leah, Shirley, Jamie, 85, 90, 86, respectively. Then Kansas team, Matthew 84%. So they all had a great month.
I'm hoping that they can have they can keep the same consistency month on month.
If no questions, then we can move on to the next slide, which is the end user CSEN. Happy to see that team is getting rave positive reviews from the partners, which makes us feel very happy. When we see happy customers, that's all we want, right? Happy end user customers.
So team has been performing very well. Shout out to Nathan. He has been getting great reviews. Then the entire Philippines team as well. Lee, Jamie, Matthew, getting amazing feedback from the end user.
Moving on with the holiday schedule. So the upcoming holiday is next month. That is Memorial Day. I will connect with Tom for New York and for other parts, we will connect with respective managers just to make sure that we have the coverage. Right now we have time.
But overall, uh...
I can say right now that we probably won't need your guys to work those days.
I will be keeping reported.
Everyone.
from New York port.
From A New York perspective, yeah, I would say that is true. I will let you know, though.
Okay.
Yeah, sure. I mean, we have like more than a month. So once we get close to the date, then we can circle back.
Right, moving on with AI by Design, I think Mike, I'm sure Lee must have reached out to you as for the AI piece. So every quarter we do have our event. So if anyone who can join from New York part or from, you know, West Coast, I know.
That's a long distance, but if you, if anyone can join, that'll be great.
Ohh.
I
Team GPS, we all know about Team GPS and Tom knows it. So we have the QR code on the screen. If you would like to schedule a demo, then do let us know. Way forward, yes, we.
We do hear Kris feedback. So thank you so much, Chris, for the feedback. We are working internally so that we can get Stella, Nixon, and Nathan enrolled in networking training. We are working on a plan. We will share the topics with you. Then if you want any changes,
then you can just let us know. But the idea is to make sure that we are helping them understand all the devices. You know, we have our in-house trainer, we have all the devices. So the idea is to get at least one hour from their busy schedule if we can. And hopefully we're looking at.
A week or two, you know, one or two weeks of training, so I'll share the curriculum with you, Kris, and then you can just help us with.
Yeah, please do, because we already went through this with Nixon and Dylan already. So I think it would be beneficial for Nathan, but I would like to understand what they're teaching them, because after I spoke to Nixon, you guys are teaching him about subnetting and layer 3 stuff when he didn't understand that a patch panel needs to be involved.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Exactly.
It's.
No, right.
So, like, that's great, but I wouldn't expect an engineer or a mechanic to start working on the head of my engine and not understand that the tires have lug nuts, so...
Yeah.
Pre.
I totally agree.
Little odd to me that they don't understand layer one or physical.
Team.
That's really what I need them to understand. I just want someone like literally just bring them into your IT closet and be like, here's what the switch looks like. Here's what an ethernet cable looks like. See how it gets patched from one end to the other? Now let's walk out to your cubicle. This is where it gets patched on this side. This is how it connects to your computer. That's how the railroad system connects to you.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
The.
Mm.
Yu.
Do it.
So, it was just really mind-blowing to me that he didn't understand that.
It is surprising to me as well because he understands the OSI model. I don't know if he got confused. I have no clue what happened. He was telling me that I know what layer one is. I asked him specifically, do you know what layer one is? He said, yes, it's physical. I was like, then you should have answered Kris. I don't know if you did not understand the question.
But given the situation, Chris, we are working on the plan. I will share the topics with you. Our main focus will be to make sure that they are physically checking all the devices. And that's why we are just taking our time so that we are working with our in-house trainer to get that
Mm.
topics for you and see how we can get it done. I don't think it's going to be more than a week, but we'll see how we can help every one of them. So Bob.
Yeah, I appreciate it. Yeah, just like I said, I think it's more of just physically seeing it will help them because like when I first started in the company, I was deploying access points and installing switches and stuff when I first started my IT career. So I think that gave me a good foundation of how to now troubleshoot behind a computer screen. But if you've never actually been in the field before and you've only started behind a computer screen,
Yeah.
Mhm.
You're at a huge disadvantage.
I 100% agree with this. And I still remember when I bought my first computer, once its warranty got expired, I opened it up just to look what's inside it. You know, so that it gives me clear understanding. So that's something
Yeah.
Appreciate it. Thank you.
Perfect. Next up, team remains focused on achieving their KPIs and meeting their benchmark scores. As we already discussed that for Q2, we just want to see how we can exceed the benchmark numbers. Rest, we are working with a team mate as per the career progression path.
We had our quarterly check-in with all of them, and we will be connecting with you to see how.
better we can do in Q2 to support engineers with their growth because when it comes to Ralph, Kyle, Stellen, I'm not including Nathan and Nixon, but these folks, they are due for their next level up. So that's something that we are working internally and we'll keep you posted.
Okay.
Rest ITBD is committed to deliver the best product and we are ready to support ID solutions with any additional needs that may come up in 2026.
Having said this, this is pretty much all for this month. I'm going to stop sharing my screen and we'll go around the table. I'll start with Tom, you first, for any questions, concerns, or feedback for us.
I do have one. I'll let Chris speak on that. I think with Nathan, we're a little concerned on some issues, but I'll let Chris speak on that. Other than that, I think Ralph and Kyle are really doing a good job. Everybody seems to be responding appropriately, doing all the right things.
I feel good that they're on, they're on the they're on the shift, particularly on the weekends. So, you know, other than that, I think the only I think the only concern right now is definitely Nathan. I'll let Chris speak on that.
Mhm.
Okay, cool. Thank you. Thank you for the for the feedback, Tom. Chris, over to you.
Yeah, so it's still kind of the same things with Nathan, right? I understand he's very green. He's definitely showing effort and wanting to learn. It's just, it's hard for me to have the time to kind of walk him through every single scenario and fully explain stuff to him because of how green he is. I try and do my best and be patient with it.
Mhm.
But sometimes it's like, I'm too busy to even take the time to be able to explain this to him. So it's just really difficult for me. I think hopefully, if we do some network training, that'll get him up to speed. And I know he keeps asking me like, what can I do instead of having admin time? So I had him update the IT glue stuff, which he did. And then he was like, I'm done. And I found errors already.
Mmh.
like right away. So I was like, well, go double check it. I haven't heard back on it yet. So it's just, I can't trust to give him anything high level or even beyond just like minutenous tasks because I just don't have that level of trust in him that's going to get done appropriately or correctly. And I'm going to have to go double check the work anyway, which is may as well I just do the work myself.
Mhm.
Those are my concerns with Nathan. And then similar, it's just the communication. Like I know it's going to be one of those things where we kind of have to work through and kind of train him and teach him how to do it. But like even today, he reached out to me and said, hey, this user can't, is accessing a shared mailbox and they're having issues. I'm like, who's the user?
And then he went on and explained the whole problem to me. I'm like, I just need to know who the user is and what mailbox I need to get to. I don't care about the backstory yet. Like all that additional information is great, but I'm not even there yet. I need to know who the user is so I can understand if this is a pressing issue or is this just a random person that isn't really that high up in the company.
The.
Mhm.
So just like responding to my questions when I'm asking questions is probably a key thing. But yeah, I just had that issue with him today. So I'm still trying to get through the growing pains.
This is.
Okay, yeah, thank you, Kris, for sharing this. And definitely, you know, from our side, we will do our level best to get him up to speed. Is it possible, can you share me the ticket number? I just would like to review this with him. You can just message me separately.
I don't even think he gave me the ticket number I can go look for, but I can send you screenshots of our chat of exactly what I was asking and his responses. So you can kind of just see what I'm talking about, where it's like I'm asking who the user is, and then
Okay.
Mhm.
20 messages later, it's like, so you want to tell me who that user is yet, or we're going to still just go around in circles.
Okay.
Yeah, anything that you can share that can help us, that'll be great. A rest, we will work with him to get him back on track.
I'll send you screenshots of that.
Yeah, absolutely.
I.
Yeah, that'd be great. And then the only other thing I had was in regards to the surveys, the monthly surveys. So I know you and I spoke about this before, about potentially changing the like review structure instead of just being a :), sad face, and a frown face, because like, it's hard for me to really give kudos to
Uh huh.
Yes.
Mhm.
Okay.
But.
Scott.
Pre.
Stellan without knocking Nixon or Nathan. Like Stellan definitely stands above Nixon and Nathan by far. He's someone I can actually have a little bit more trust in. Nixon and Nathan, it's if they're working tickets, I don't hear complaints, awesome. But I'm definitely not trusting them with some type of high level support or a VIP client.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Mhm, mhm.
Mm.
Mhm.
So if there's any way to put like a rating system there where it's like a one through 10, and I can put a :) and give him a 7 or an 8 as opposed to a 10, and then I can give Stella A10 or something to that effect, that may be able to help you guys gauge our feedback to them a little bit better than just :), :), neutral face.
Okay.
Mm.
Because then you reach out to me and say, why does Nathan get a neutral? I go, well, because he's not as good as Nixon and Nate, as Stellin, so I can't give him the same credit.
Yeah.
But I...
You won't believe this, Chris. I said the same thing to everyone. Trust me, I did. You can ask Manish. You know, I told Manish that Chris is filling the sun because I don't blame Chris because we have three options. If a person is doing okay, then the person who is okay, right? If Stylin is doing great, then obviously,
Hi, Olivia.
I believe ya.
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Is doing great, so I, I, I totally understand where you're coming from.
Yeah, I just think it's a poor system in the way to rate somebody because like, I can't really give due credit where it's due with Stellans. Like he has taken on RMW. There's mistakes that happen, right? We all make mistakes. So, but he's really taken the bull by the horns and owning that. And I give him a lot of credit for it. Nixon,
Mhm.
So.
He does a good job, he gets the tickets done, but...
Nothing really glowing to say, nothing really negative to say, and then Nathan under the hand is just...
Hmm. Yeah.
Started.
He's getting tickets done is a slower pace, not as good as everybody else. If we replaced them today, I'd probably feel no pain.
Select.
Okay, yeah, and also, you know, just to add to this, our C set.
James.
Sing.
Is is a global thing, so I definitely we we take your feedback. We'll try to see if for.
Mhm.
Yes.
Just for ideal solution, if we can make that change, OK, then instead of CSAT, we can give you that scale that you're talking about, but for the time being, if you can, you know, do this, that put your ratings in the comments, right, so that we can also see, you know, how things are when you say that still 10 out of 10.
Yeah.
There.
OK, that's what I was about to say.
Okay.
We'll be more than happy to take it. Then if Nixon or Nathan is on like 5, 6, 7, it will give us an idea that okay, this is where they are lacking and they're supposed to reach to 10, right, rather than being on six or seven.
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Yes.
No, exactly. It just gives you guys a gauge of like month to month how they're improving or something. Where if I say, hey, Nathan's a four this month and then next month he's a six, cool, we're going in the right direction. Or the next month he goes down to a three, oh no, we're aggressing, something needs to be done. So it just gives you guys a better understanding of how we actually feel about the engineers. I know we speak on this call, but
Absolutely, absolutely.
Needle is moving.
Yeah.
If I'm going to do the review, I want to actually make sure it's meaningful and impactful.
Absolutely. And I think for now, I mean, as I've said, that we will definitely work on your feedback. But for the time being, if you can just put your rating in the comments, that will be awesome. Okay. Until then, unless we get that scale for you. Okay. But I truly appreciate your candid feedback, Chris, as always. And we have work to do. We know it.
Yu.
Yeah, will do.
Sounds good.
and we definitely will see the needle work. So that's something that's on us. Okay. Great. So thank you, Chris, once again. Yep. And Mike, over to you for any questions, concerns, or feedback from us.
There. Perfect. And that's all I had. Thank you.
No, and again, I apologize for my crappy internet connection if I'm dropping in and out, but I really appreciate the opportunity to be on here with you guys and Level Set. Always a little concerned with the poor performers, but I think we're addressing those and really appreciate you guys' help on that.
Yep, you're most welcome, Mike, and your connection is much, much better now. So I can tell you that. I can hear you crystal clear. So thank you. And thank you so much for your feedback. Appreciate it. Okay, Andy, anything from your end?
Yes.
Sorry.
Very good. Thank you.
Nope, nothing. Just happy to meet you all. Happy almost Friday.
For you.
Thank you, Andy Ayra.
Hey, everyone, this is my first time seeing Mike, Zavos, I believe, Leah, Shella, and Jamie is working with you. So, if any, if you need any help from these guys, you can ping me or Kawandeep, but then it's nice to see you here.
I.
Will do, thank you.
Thank you, Ayra. Manish, anything from your end?
Yeah, Chris, thank you for sharing that feedback regarding Nathan. So as you mentioned, you'll be sharing some of the information, like specifics for what is to be worked upon, like the screenshot. So we'll definitely work on that and we'll be taking care of it.
And like, as Ayra mentioned, it's a first time for me as well to see Tom and Mike. Thank you, both of you, for joining this call, and we'll be looking forward to work with you all together.
All right. Thank you. Thank you, Manish. Thank you so much. So team, we give you 5 minutes back. So thank you everyone for joining in and we'll see you next month. Till then, have a good one. Take care. Bye bye.
Thank you.
So.
This guy is always a pleasure.
Take care.
Always a pleasure, guys. Take care. Bye.
Thanks, everybody.
Take.
Abe.
Thank you.
Yeah.